А зараз - «heute journal» з Гайнцом Вольфом
і Марієттою Сломкою.
Доброго вечора, міністр закордонних справ України
нещодавно порівняв боротьбу за Донбас
із боями Другої світової війни.
І справді, переглядаючи відео з війни в Україні,
де солдати стріляють з окопів,
або в закамуфльованих листям танках
підстерігають ворога на лісових галявинах,
дійсно можна подумати,
що дивишся кадри з Другої чи навіть
Першої світової війни.
І всі ці руйнування також як страшне дежавю:
цілі міста й села знищені вщент.
Російська армія зосереджується на Сході України,
щоб будь-якою ціною досягти того,
чого не досягла в інших областях.
Українці побоюються, що після цього
знову почнеться масований наступ на Півдні.
Саме там зараз наш репортер, Йоганес Гано.
Рибальська ідилія на річці Дністер,
близько 50 км на південь від Одеси.
Звідси вже не так далеко до Молдови та Румунії.
Але ця ідилія оманлива.
І сюди також вже давно прийшла війна.
Ми всі напружені та схвильовані.
Щодня ми чуємо сирени.
Ми всі чекаємо на контрнаступ наших військових
та швидше завершення війни.
Недалеко звідси, у гирлі річки,
крилаті ракети,
випущені зі стратегічних бомбардувальників та
військових кораблів,
зруйнували стратегічно важливий міст,
яким надходили поставки з Румунії.
З міркувань безпеки ми не можемо його показати.
Тепер постачання відбуваються
об'їзним шляхом з Молдови,
Що заховано під брезентом, можна лише здогадуватися.
У місті-мільйоннику Одесі вже навчилися жити
під постійною загрозою.
Над містом регулярно лунають сирени,
але люди ігнорують повітряну тривогу.
Влада наголошує, що це і є для них
найбільшою небезпекою,
адже вже декілька разів від початку війни
ракети влучали і в цивільні будівлі.
«Нам не можна недооцінювати небезпеку», -
каже речник голови Одеської ОВА.
Небезпечно у місті,
ракети можуть влучити будь-якої миті,
навіть сюди, де ми зараз стоїмо.
Але також ми чітко розуміємо, що ми не здамося
і переможемо.
З узбережжя українські військові
уважно вдивляються в горизонт.
У гарну погоду там, на великій відстані від Одеси,
можна побачити російські військові кораблі.
Зараз ми в одному з численних укріплень міста.
Тут українські військові готуються
до російської десантної операції.
Ми ще з початку війни очікуємо їхнього приходу
та щодня зміцнюємо наші укріплення.
І хоча зараз в Одесі тихо, на думку солдат,
цей спокій оманливий.
Вони вважають, що російські війська
ще не відмовилися від мети захопити Одесу.
Бувають дні, коли над нашими позиціями
літають 20-30 їхніх дронів.
Військові кажуть, що декілька таких вони вже збили.
Знову і знову ворожі дрони
спостерігають за українськими оборонними позиціями.
Українська розвідка попереджає населення:
на військові кораблі та підводні човни
неподалік від узбережжя завантажено нові ракети.
Для кремлівського стратега Одеса -
стратегічно важлива ціль.
А зараз ми поговоримо з Йоганесом Гано.
Йоганесе, у сюжеті ти сказав,
що Одеса є для росіян
надзвичайно важливою ціллю.
Так, Одеса є морськими воротами України.
Це найбільший порт і тут відбувається найбільше
торговельних операцій, зокрема -
експорт зернових та соняшнику для всього світу.
Також через цей порт Україна отримує
промислові товари.
І Путін ніколи не приховував
свого бажання взяти Одесу,
а згодом і зовсім відрізати Україну від моря.
Україна побоюється, що саме це він і планує,
і наголошує, що намагатиметься втримати місто будь-якими силами,
адже його втрата мала б для країни
важкі економічні та політичні наслідки.
Війна завжди значною мірою залежить від логістики.
Це стосується обох сторін.
Наскільки проблематичною є зараз для України
організація поповнення запасів?
Минулими тижнями російські війська почали
масовані ракетні атаки на українську інфраструктуру.
Постраждали залізничні шляхи й заводи,
зокрема й нафтопереробні.
І це відчутно. Бензину вже не вистачає.
Багато АЗС закрилося.
Дизель потрібен для армії, тому його можна придбати
не більше 15 л на день, якщо взагалі вдасться.
Є також і інші проблеми.
Наприклад, поставки зброї з ЄС, які
через згаданий в сюжеті зруйнований міст
тепер також неможливо здійснювати через Румунію,
а лише вузькими дорогами Молдови.
Проте дуже складно транспортувати все це суходолом.
Але, як повідомили нам військові, поки що
поповнення запасів не переривається.
Передусім надходить легке озброєння.
Проте поставки важкої зброї занадто повільні,
особливо враховуючи те, що російські війська
стягують сили
у Херсонській області, що приблизно за 140 км звідси,
і з високою ймовірністю у якийсь момент
таки почнуть наступ.
Дякуємо Йоганесу за включення з Одеси.
Триває також і економічна війна.
ЄС все ще намагається дійти згоди
щодо ембарго на російську нафту.
Точніше, політики хочуть таки залучити до цього
й прем'єр-міністра Угорщини Віктора Орбана.
До речі, Україна нещодавно висловила Орбану
акуратну погрозу,
наголосивши, що нафтопровід,
через який Угорщина отримує нафту, проходить
через Україну,
і, на жаль, не виключено,
що з ним може «щось статися».
Поки саміт ЄС сумнівається, що з цього вийде,
країни G7
на сьогоднішній зустрічі в Берліні досягли компромісу.
Сім провідних розвинених країн уперше
повідомляють про рішення
щодо поетапної відмови від вугілля.
Для певних регіонів це буде серйозним викликом.
Далі - Калд Гінтерляйтнер.
Скло для промисловості та побуту
вже 400 років виготовляє
середнє родинне підприємство «Heinz» в місті Нойгаус,
що у федеральній землі Тюрингія.
З огляду на рекордне зростання цін на енергоносії,
керівниця вперше непокоїться
за майбутнє своєї компанії.
Це сильно б’є по нас, наше підприємство
дуже енергоємне,
нам потрібно багато газу, багато електроенергії,
тому працювати з такими десятикратними цінами
для нас - надзвичайний виклик.
Бути економічно ефективним та екологічним водночас.
Саме про це йшлося на зустрічі
міністрів захисту довкілля та енергетики країн G7
біля колишнього газометра у Берліні.
Необхідно відмовитися від викопного палива.
І хоча Німеччина й досі його імпортує, вона,
за словами міністра економіки й захисту клімату,
рішуче налаштована на перехід до «зеленої» енергії.
Ми діємо так через необхідність,
і все, що ми зараз робимо, це не предмет гордості,
а лише запобіжний захід
для попередження надзвичайної ситуації.
І цілком правильним є зараз проконтролювати
всі ці процеси, щоб згодом застосування викопного палива
знову не набуло широких масштабів.
Власне цього й хотіли досягнути на саміті,
але домовленості, яких було досягнуто,
не зобов'язують до швидких та конкретних дій.
Так, електропостачання до 2035 року повинне відбуватися
«переважно» без викопного палива,
а дорожній рух «значною мірою» - до 2035.
А ще 100 млрд євро буде виділено
на захист клімату країн, що розвиваються.
І хоча 7 передових промислових країн і заявляють,
що мають намір відмовитися від вугілля,
конкретної дати вони не називають.
Попри це, міністерка захисту довкілля
робить позитивний висновок.
Це була хороша зустріч.
Добре, що ми зустрілися особисто.
Я сьогодні поїду додому з хорошим відчуттям,
адже ця зустріч країн G7 була успішною
для захисту клімату,
природи та довкілля.
Передусім США та Німеччина хочуть діяти спільно
для розширення використання відновлюваних
джерел енергії, тому вони сьогодні підписали
відповідну угоду.
Критики схвалюють такий напрям руху, але кажуть,
що реалізація таких домовленостей повинна
відбуватися краще,
ніж після попередніх самітів.
Це середньо- та довгострокове партнерство
означає не лише
досягнення компромісу щодо спільних цілей.
Ми його вже досягли, уклавши Паризьку угоду.
Це партнерство означає, що ми повинні діяти спільно
для швидшого досягнення цих цілей.
Для організацій з охорони довкілля такі формулювання
занадто абстрактні,
а рішення саміту вони вважають недостатньо рішучими.
Вони все ще не діють
згідно зі своєю міжнародною відповідальністю.
Країни G7 мали б зобов'язатися
відмовитись від вугілля до 2030 року, не виробляти
та не експортувати
автомобілів з двигунами внутрішнього згоряння
з 2030 року.
За захист клімату бореться й
підприємиця Карлетта Гайнц.
Але відновлюваних джерел енергії,
як і раніше, недостатньо,
і насамперед їй потрібна доступна енергія,
щоб її підприємство з 400-річною історією
могло продовжувати працювати.
Після стрілянини в Техаській школі
в Сполучених Штатах знову почалися дебати
щодо права на зброю.
Це відбувається щоразу й аргументи давно відомі.
Демократи хочуть посилити закони про зброю
та загалом зменшити кількість зброї в країні.
Республіканці, з іншого боку, дотримуються
аргументів збройового лобі:
такі стрілянини доводять,
що кожен громадянин має мати можливість
захистити себе.
Згадується, як Дональд Трамп
за часів свого президенства
зажадав, щоб вчителі були краще озброєні
після стрілянини у школі у Флориді.
Однак ця і без того дуже особлива логіка
зовсім не поєднується з тим, що ми зараз дізнаємось
про перебіг злочину в Техасі: вочевидь,
навіть озброєні правоохоронці
спочатку не наважувалися протистояти злочинцеві.
Про це повідомляє Клаудія Бейтс.
Чи зупиняться Американські шанувальники зброї
після ще 21 загиблого, 19 з яких-
учні початкової школи?
Потужне збройове лобі «NRA» зараз зібралося в Техасі,
очікують також і прибуття Дональда Трампа.
Багато політиків, особливо республіканців,
відстоюють свою позицію.
Вони скаржаться, що демократи хочуть використати
випадок зі стріляниною
як доказ, що треба посилити закони про зброю.
Але з ними це не пройде.
Нам потрібно більше зброї та більше безпеки.
Зброя захищає людей.
Зброя не вбиває. Люди вбивають.
З якого Ви телеканалу? Німецького?
Це питання менталітету, вам цього ніколи не зрозуміти.
Родичі вбитих дітей
тепер, крім скорботи, відчувають гнів.
Батьки були вже були біля школи, коли зловмисник
досі був усередині.
Приблизно 40 правоохоронців також були там,
але не вживали заходів.
Батьки благали поліцію врятувати їхніх дітей,
однак їх відштовхували назад.
Люди казали:
«Йдіть в школу, схопіть його, йдіть».
Кожну хвилину він когось убивав.
Кожну хвилину ми чули постріл.
Але ніхто не хотів наражатися на небезпеку,
тому ніхто й не пішов.
Ці діти не мали померти.
Через 12 хвилин перші правоохоронці
прибули на місце злочину,
але зникли до того, як злочинець почав стріляти.
Навіть підкріпленню федеральної поліції
керівник оперативними діями спочатку
не дав дозволу зайти до школи.
Він думав, що злочинець забарикадувався,
а дітям нічого не загрожує.
Дзвінки маленької дівчинки крають душу.
Вона телефонує правоохоронцям з класної кімнати.
12:03, дзвінок тривав 1 хвилину 23 секунди.
Вона назвала своє ім’я і прошепотіла,
що перебуває в кімнаті 112.
О 12:10 вона знову дзвонить,
каже, що є кілька вбитих.
О 12:43 та о 12:47 вона просить
негайно надіслати поліцію.
Але лише через 20 хвилин чиновники
вживають заходів.
Якщо озирнутися назад, це, безумовно,
було неправильним рішення. Крапка.
І цьому немає виправдання.
Але чи є якісь наслідки?
У парламенті зібралася група сенаторів:
республіканців та демократів.
Вони обговорюватимуть закони про зброю.
Однак заборона на зброю навіть не обговорюється.
А зараз передаю слово Гайнцу Вольфу.
Канцлер Німеччини Олаф Шольц сьогодні був
на католицькому святі у Штутґарті.
У своїй промові він вкотре засудив
війну Росії проти України
та пояснив позицію та дії федерального уряду.
І тому мені цілком зрозуміло:
Путіну не може зійти з рук
його цинічна, нелюдська війна.
Саме тому є жорсткі санкції проти Росії,
саме тому є підтримка України:
гуманітарна, економічна і фінансова.
І саме тому ми доставляємо зброю
до зони бойових дій,
чого ми ще ніколи не робили
як Федеративна Республіка.
Другою міністеркою, що відвідала Україну
з початку війни
є міністерка економічного співробітництва тарозвитку
Свенья Шульце.
Вона відвідала зруйноване місто Бородянка
у передмісті Києва
та пообіцяла допомогу у відбудові,
зокрема у відбудові житла та ліній електропередач.
І за словами Шульце, не варто чекати
закінчення війни,
треба вже зараз починати допомагати
і відбудовувати.
Поліція Кельна веде слідчі дії щодо 70 підозрюваних,
які, за даними, володіли та обмінювалися
численними фотографіями та відеозаписами
сексуального насильства над немовлятами
та маленькими дітьми.
Відправним пунктом є провадження в Берліні,
де під час слідства знайшли чоловіка
із Північного Рейн-Вестфалії,
який вів списки підозрюваних у педофілії.
Прокуратура та поліція нададуть
додаткові подробиці розслідування
на пресконференції у понеділок.
Іранський «Корпус вартових ісламської революції»
затримав два грецькі нафтові танкери
в Перській затоці.
Причиною було вказано
порушення суднами правил.
Греція протестувала проти таких дій
та вказала, що це акт піратства.
Цьому передувала суперечка між двома країнами
через танкер, що перевозив іранську нафту
та нещодавно був затриманий у грецьких водах.
У Демократичній Республіці Конго
десятки тисяч людей
змушені тікати через нові запеклі бої
між урядом та повстанцями тутсі.
Агентство ООН у справах біженців
висловило стурбованість
переміщенням загалом приблизно
72 тис жителів на сході країни.
Багатьом не вистачає житла,
їжі та чистої води.
З кінця минулого року
неодноразово відбувалися бої
між повстанською організацією тутсі
та урядовими військами.
Яка зараз ситуація з коронавірусом?
Адже тема не закрита лише тому,
що інші катастрофи відволікають від неї нашу увагу.
Наразі показники падають.
Втім, не лише міністр охорони здоров'я Німеччини
стурбований тим, що нас очікує восени.
Лаутербах хотів би знову запровадити такі заходи,
як, наприклад, обов'язкове носіння масок
у приміщенні.
Однак це зовсім не подобається партії FDP,
і тому у «світлофорній» коаліції знову шумно.
Тим часом стає все очевиднішим,
що зараження не призводить
до швидкого підвищення імунітету у населення,
як деякі сподівались.
На жаль, заразитися можна повторно.
Петра Отто про випадки повторного інфікування.
Жінка, що тричі вакцинувалась
і двічі хворіла на коронавірус.
Джесіці Рейзінгер 27 років, вона абсолютно здорова,
чула про повторні інфікування, але була здивована,
коли це трапилось і з нею.
Звісно, я усвідомлювала, що заразитися можна і там,
де раніше я просто цього не очікувала.
Але після першого зараження я подумала,
що мені вже це не загрожує.
Втім, повторне інфікування
не така вже й рідкість.
У департаменті охорони здоров’я Штутґарта
проаналізували дані.
І вони показують, що кількість повторних інфікувань,
тобто множинних заражень, збільшується.
Навіть досить різко, відколи Омікрон
почав переважати з початку року.
І майже кожне третє повторне інфікування
виявляють у молоді.
Насправді, це й не дивно,
адже саме ця вікова група має
багато соціальних контактів
та є мобільною.
Але ні загострення захворювання,
ні підвищення рівня госпіталізацій
у разі повторного інфікування
ми не спостерігаємо.
А якщо поглянути на статистику,
то можна помітити, що люди похилого віку
досить рідко заражаються повторно
і до того ж добре захищені.
Ці показники досить багато чого пояснюють.
Однак це не є
репрезентативним науковим дослідженням.
Репрезентативні дослідження повторного інфікування
проводять у Англії, Данії та Катарі.
З іншого боку, Німеччина має
очевидні структурні проблеми,
каже медичний статистик Ґерд Антес.
Немає планування, немає координування.
Якщо департамент охорони здоров'я має
хороші показники, це добре для Штутґарта.
Але ми хочемо отримати загальну картину
для всієї Німеччини,
особливо через різний відсоток вакцинованих.
І тому не вистачає координування
на державному рівні.
Так було з першої секунди.
Як ваша імунна система реагує на вірус?
Чи були щеплення марними?
В Дюссельдорфі у відділі вірусології досліджують
як тіло позбувається вірусу.
На відміну від інфекції кору, на яку достатньо
захворіти один раз, аби більше нею не хворіти,
у разі коронавірусу недостатньо антитіл, які
виробилися під час хвороби.
Для респіраторних захворювань це типово.
Цей імунітет, який створює організм, зазвичай не
залишається
на слизових оболонках так надовго.
Саме тому ми знову і знову
контактуємо з тими ж збудниками
і заражаємося тим самим вірусом.
Багато хто думав, що достатньо щеплення чи
просто перехворіти,
аби позбутися пандемії.
Щодо Джессіки Рейзінгер, то в неї
перебіг хвороби був легким
і вона, ймовірно, нікого не заразила.
Вона впевнена, що добре бути вакцинованим,
попри те, що вона вже двічі хворіла.
Замовити онлайн замість того, щоб піти в магазин:
саме так робило більшість людей під час пандемії.
Однак зараз для споживачів відбудуться певні зміни,
Гайнц.
Безкоштовне повернення вже стало звичним і
очікуваним для споживачів, це повідомила
Федеральна асоціація електронної комерції
та доставки газеті «Süddeutsche Zeitung».
Виникає питання: якою буде ситуація надалі,
зокрема у галузі одягу та моди?
Зіна Майніц на фондовій біржі,
яка ситуація в бізнесі поштових доставок?
Все міняється, тому ситуація з онлайн-шопінгом
в майбутньому може дещо ускладнитися.
Іспанська мережа одягу «Zara» і Японський бренд
«Uniqlo» вже стягують
за повернення посилки від 2-3 євро
за один пакет.
Транспортування, пакування, персонал -
за все це потрібно заплатити
і споживач повинен бути залучений до цього.
За бумом замовлень в Інтернеті часто слідує
бум повернень.
Німеччина є чемпіоном з кількості повернень в
Європі - 75%.
Для одягу ця частка становить 50%.
Це означає, що 800 000 посилок на день
повертають назад.
Фактор витрат, але перед усім
надмірна експлуатація навколишнього середовища
та сталий розвиток.
Викиди CO2 прирівнюють до 255 поїздок на авто
з Франкфурта до Пекіна, і це лише за один день.
Перші компанії скасували безкоштовне повернення,
однак такі великі дилери як
«Amazon», «Zalando» чи «Otto»
поки що виступають проти скасування.
На їхню думку, повернення і надалі має залишатися
безкоштовним.
Сьогодні німецький фондовий ринок не впав,
а навпаки - піднявся стрімко вгору.
Dax завершив торги більш ніж на півтора відсотка
до 14 462 пунктів.
Барометр фондової біржі досяг 5-тижневого
максимуму
за короткий термін.
Інвестори більш оптимістично налаштовані протягом
останніх торговельних днів
чарівного місяця травня.
Зіно Майніц, красно дякую.
На Відкритому чемпіонаті Франції з тенісу
Анжеліка Кербер не потрапила до 1/8 фіналу.
Вона програла гру в третьому раунді
Олександрі Соснович із Білорусі.
Олександр Звєрєв увійшов до 1/8 фіналу,
завдяки своїй перемозі у грі з американцем
Брендоном Накашимою.
ФК «Ліверпуль» і «Реал Мадрид» готуються до
фіналу Ліги чемпіонів,
завтра на Стад-де-Франс у Парижі.
Фінал дивіться у прямому ефірі на ZDF о 20:25,
а вже о 19:20 на вас чекає випуск про Лігу чемпіонів.
У деяких людей відчуття туги асоціюється
з Парижем.
У спорті це стосується двох найкращих
футбольних команд Європи.
«Ліверпуль» під керівництвом Юргена Клоппа
втретє за 5 років
у Фіналі кубка європейських чемпіонів.
Суперник «Реал Мадрид» є рекордсменом.
Незабутній фінал 2018 року, у якому
червоним не пощастило.
Логічно, що я почуватимуся краще,
якщо цього разу ми виграємо
і зараз я думаю про те, як це втілити.
Після перемоги у двох національних кубках,
«Ліверпуль»
міг би завтра виграти свій третій титул.
На Каннському кінофестивалі
один із найкращих фільмів
навіть не брав участі в конкурсі.
Однак там він відсвяткував свою світову прем’єру.
Критики - у цілковитому захваті.
Наша кіноекспертка Забіне Шульц
також вважає його неймовірним,
а це вже щось означає.
Успіхом фільм значною мірою завдячує
молодому актору,
який наважився зіграти роль легенди.
Як грати Елвіса Преслі?
Хто вміє співати й рухатися так,
аби це не виглядало як пародія?
Але ми бачимо людину, яка зуміла це.
Після прем'єри можна бути впевненим:
народилася нова зірка.
Але Елвіс - не єдиний головний герой цього фільму.
Його менеджер також грає значну роль,
а також його дружина Прісцилла.
77 річна Прісцилла Преслі прибула у Канни
на прем'єру фільму
про кохання всього її життя: «ЕЛВІС».
Режисер фільму - Баз Лурман,
відомий австралієць зі своїм унікальним почерком.
Фільм швидко стане відомим всьому світу:
короля рок-н-ролу зіграв Остін Батлер,
а його сумнівного менеджера Тома Паркера
- Том Хенкс.
Я хочу бути вашим менеджером містер Преслі.
Ви готові до польоту?
Я готовий, готовий до польоту.
Паркер нічого не знав про музику, але він
розгледів в Елвісі
золоту копальню, він бачив,
реакцію дам на рух стегон Преслі.
«Без мене не було б Елвіса Преслі».
Паркер був нікчемним шахраєм, який шукав
швидких грошей.
Однак, він зробив добре усім.
От тільки - він усіх обікрав, і Елвіса також,
та встиг покласти багато грошей до власної кишені.
Але Елвіс був бунтарем.
Він не дотримувався жодних правил.
Він не мав поняття, що він зробив.
Важкі відносини між Паркером та Елвісом
на мою думку, ідеально підійшли,
аби показати Америку
50-х, 60-х, 70-х років та висвітлити тогочасний
расизм.
Я хотів намалювати велику картину Америки,
яка також відбивала б те, де ми знаходимося
сьогодні.
Трагедія, але нас це ніяк не стосується.
Ще й як стосується.
Є люди, які хочуть посадити мене за ґрати за те,
як я рухаюся.
Мене хочуть посадити за ґрати лише за те, що
що я переходжу вулицю,
але ж ти - відомий білий хлопчина.
Білий, котрий зробив музику темношкірих
прийнятною для суспільства.
Тоді - в часи расової сегрегації -
це було провокацією.
У нас не було б Елвіса без музики та культури
афроамериканців.
Він виріс у кварталі, де було багато темношкірих,
це було його натхненням,
він любив ходити на службу до євангельської
церкви.
На сцені молодий співак з Мемфіса, Теннессі.
Від свого початку до падіння зірки у 70-х роках.
* музика *
Жадібність Паркера вважають однією із причин
ранньої смерті Елвіса у віці 42 років.
Навіть шлюб з Прісциллою не зміг його врятувати.
Дикий, яскравий ― і водночас складний
та чудовий фільм.
Гра Остіна Батлера гідна «Оскара».
Зал аплодував стоячи під час прем'єри в Каннах.
Щирі емоції і благословення Прісцилли Преслі.
Ще жоден фільм, за її словами, не показав так вдало
особистість Елвіса.
Наразі все, далі «heute-show».
О 00:25 на вас чекає Гундула Гаузе
в «heute-journal:update».
А завтра о 21:45 - Ліга чемпіонів.
Зустрінемося згодом, до побачення.
Доброго вечора.
На холодній ноті травень добігає кінця.
І це завдяки цьому холодному фронту,
який за ці години
досягнув Альп.
Буде дуже вітряно,
північно-західний вітер
та холодне повітря охопить всю Німеччину.
Сьогодні вночі будуть зливи та гроза на
Півночі Німеччини,
в цій частині все зрозуміло.
І маленький холодний фронт супроводжується
дощами в Альпах.
На півдні ніч досить м'яка, також густа хмарність.
Від 12° до 10°.
На Північному морі сьогодні вночі буде 10°,
однак на решті території температура
становитиме між 9° та 4°.
А в низьких гірських хребтах очікуються навіть
легкі заморозки.
Завтра теж буде прохолодно, максимальна
температура протягом доби
становитиме між 13° та 17° і, можливо, в середній
частині
та на Верхньому Рейні від 18° до 20°.
Завтра вранці на краю Альп трохи дощитиме,
а потім все вщухне, спостерігатиметься невелика
хмарність.
Завтра буде погодний мікс - сонце, хмари, дощі,
місцями блискавка і грім.
Найсильніші зливи, ймовірно, будуть між Берліном і
Північною Фрисландією, там очікується
сильний штормовий вітер
з північно-західних напрямків.
Мало що зміниться в неділю.
Стане трохи прохолодніше.
Але потім на новому тижні
з кожним днем ставатиме тепліше.
У середу за календарем починається літо,
температура підійматиметься до 29°.
А ось і коливання температур в
Гарміш-Партенкірхен, бачимо, що
в суботу вона була 11°
і досягла 30°, однак в четвер знову впала.
Гарного вечора.